le Demeter
en charter de Roumanie à Londres
expédiant le contenu de caisses privées
inconnues
en mer sans terre en vue
cette année arrive,
il est habillé comme un érudit
Université de Cambridge Je connais mon chemin
autour du bateau notre Charter a accepté
de payer un bonus pour le respect des délais  numéro d'arrivée
le navire
ici est de la myrtille,
nous ne venons pas avec comme ce bâton d'
offres, c'est clair
pour moi c'est une ceinture de ventilateur. Aucun doute,
quelque chose de vrai à propos des animaux
sur le bétail, cela ressemble à une bouchée,
fouillez le navire partout où
le mal ne s'ennuie pas
[  Musique]
puissant maléfique
[Musique]
les gars
la nuit, il boit notre sang, il est juste
là,
nous l'appelons
ordinateur,
il vient
si facilement, cette foutue chose
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
que Dieu ait pitié de nous tous